can a Hebrew speaker understand an
Arabic speaker well the short answer is
no the long answer is kind of sorta
maybe but not really know the question
of the day is how similar are Hebrew and
Arabic as someone who has studied both
languages I get asked this question by
quite a few people and it's a good
question it makes me think because not
quite sure but I'll give you my best
answer basically Hebrew and Arabic are
very closely related languages and study
both that will become very apparent
you'll see tons of similarities and if
you know one well already that will help
you learn the other much more easily but
at the same time they are not mutually
comprehensible that means you if you
speak one and not the other and you
won't be able to communicate with
someone who speaks the other language so
they're not you can't you can't
communicate as though they're the same
language it won't work okay so let's
talk about some things that are kind of
similar and I'll throw in some
differences as I go and then I'll talk
about how they're not really useful as a
communication tool with each other
okay so they're similar in terms of the
verbal system and in terms of how you
create words in the language so in both
Hebrew and Arabic they have a system of
roots now those roots are usually three
consonant letters and you take those
three consonant letters and you put them
into kind of templates that help you
create a word so the templates are
patterns they're like a set of a
combination of vowels and affixes that
could be a prefix or a suffix or even an
infix inside the word so let's take a
three-letter root and I'll give you an
example in Hebrew you've got the root
cut uh that's KTV if you romanize it and
in arabic you've got cut but KTB if you
romanize it already you can see there's
a similarity that root is almost the
same the buck and the v''e are different
but those sounds are
so if you put them into the templates
you can change it let's use a verb
conjugation template in the past tense
this is the simplest structure in both
languages so in Hebrew if you say I
wrote you would say catotti in Arabic
you would say kitab - or in a dialect
maybe cut up in Hebrew for the second
person masculine for you you would say
cut a vita in arabic kitab 'te so you
can see that's quite similar for the
feminine second person singular in
Hebrew you would say tuft in Arabic you
would say catotti okay so you could see
there there's a similarity here in the
way that you put the roots into these
templates to conjugate the verbs and you
can see that the conjugations are kind
of similar the templates are kind of
similar but they're not exactly the same
and there could be confusion like for
for the one I said for in Hebrew it's
catotti that's I wrote but catotti in
Arabic means you wrote it's when spoken
to a female so you can see there could
be a confusion there you might
misunderstand I think they're talking
about someone else right but you can see
that's the same kind of system and that
that kind of system of templates is used
to create nouns to create adjectives all
kinds of words just the templates are
different and have different ethics is
attached to them and different vowels so
that's one thing is that system of roots
and templates it's the same in both so
if you learned that once for one
language is that just getting that
concept down really helps you with the
second language that uses that same
system because it's a bit mind-bending
at first did adjust to that root end
template system another way that they're
similar is in terms of just a lot of
vocabulary you already saw that that one
root the cut the vine cut the book so
there's a lot of vocabulary that's the
same it's not the majority of words
though it's not like 80 percent or
something like that it's I would I don't
know the exact percentage I would guess
that it's about 1/3 and that's just off
the top of my head from my studying
experience a third some of the words are
very similar or almost the same
some are some are clearly related if you
examine the words but you might not
notice that just from hearing them
because the phonology of the languages
has become different due to the
languages history
yeah it's similar in French and Italian
the French and Italian if you read two
sentences equivalent sentences
side-by-side you can look at them and
you can say oh this word must be the
same as this word this one must be the
same as this one because the the words
look kind of similar they sound
different and the spelling is different
but you can look at them and see that
they're the same they have the same
meaning because they look similar if
there are a lot of words like that like
they're the kind of cognates but they're
they're slightly different so I'll give
you some examples of both types like the
ones that are very similar
Yod in Hebrew and Arabic that means hand
dumb in Hebrew and Arabic that means
blood right there's a lot of words that
are similar like that or almost the same
like that some that you can figure out
quite easily like with the pronouns like
I is on the in Hebrew or I'm not in
Arabic or in Hebrew you for a man is a
top in Arabic gets on top right he is
who in Hebrew it's huwa in Arabic right
and that might depend on the dialect -
in Arabic it's different in from country
to country another one kitchen in Hebrew
Mitzvah and in Arabic it's matzah so
pretty close just one vowel changes in
the Arabic one some that are a little
bit more different but you can see the
similarity especially if you know the
function or meaning of the word like
this one to you or for you in Hebrew is
the ha but an Arabic get slack so if you
look at the vowels sorry if you look at
the consonants you can see ok L K versus
l CH those might be the same right I've
in Hebrew his father AB in Arabic so
again you see that B and the V another
one been his son in Hebrew even his son
in Arabic so if we just look at the
consonants the B in the end you can say
oh those are related another one
rush-rush means head
in Hebrew and thus thus means head in
Arabic so thus and Rosh dolls are
clearly related another one tongue in
Hebrew Lashon in Arabic lee-san
lisanne so the Sun and the show hmm
maybe there's a change there and also
the the all became an ah sound so
there's some shifts in the sounds are
going on dog in Hebrew is caliph in
Arabic it's Kulp so you can see there
are a lot of words that have a similar
similar root or they they come from the
same word but they've shifted and become
different there's a lot of words like
that that you wouldn't necessarily
understand when you hear them another
one that's this there are some words
that are the same but they have a
different meaning like uh Medina or
Medina in Hebrew Medina is state like
madinat Israel the State of Israel but
in Arabic Medina means a city so they're
both political entities there's a
connection in the meaning but it's not
exactly the same meaning the meaning has
become different and there are also a
lot of words that are just different
entirely for whatever reason it's always
kind of strange to discover words that
are exactly the same and Hebrew and
Arabic and then the next word in the
sentence is entirely different and
you've never seen it before so why did
this one become the same in both
languages but this one is different
why so it makes it kind of interesting I
don't always know usually don't know the
answer but yeah anyway there's a lot of
different vocabulary so you can see that
they're quite related and there's a lot
of crossover but you won't understand
one just by learning the other right it
will help you learn the other if you
make the effort though and if you take
what you know and try to apply it to the
other language while learning so let me
give you an example of when I first went
to Egypt in 1997 I went there after
having studied Hebrew for a couple years
already and I was visiting Israel and I
went to Egypt too so I tried to use my
Hebrew and apply it to Arabic because I
only knew a little bit of Arabic I
didn't know enough to really to have a
conversation or whatever so I would try
to use my very simple Arabic and insert
Hebrew words into it and
I knew the difference in phonology so I
would kind of shift and arabised my
pronunciation of the Hebrew words and I
was surprised by how often people
understood me
and the people didn't speak Hebrew they
weren't hebrew speakers but they
understood i guess they could they could
hear the word and think of an equivalent
or similar sounding word in arabic or
they could hear the root and maybe that
root was used in a different word in
their Arabic dialect or whatever so they
could figure out what I was saying a lot
of the time and they looked at me
strangely they thought maybe I was a
weirdo or
I remember they often asked me if I was
from Lebanon so maybe they thought that
my bizarre Arabic pidgin language was
Lebanese Arabic that seemed to be
something like that they kept asking me
if I was from Lebanon it happened like
that in Jordan - I remember when I was
in Jordan the same year that III managed
to use some Hebrew words in situations
where I was surprised that it went
across so they understood a lot of my
Hebrew words when I arabised them so
that's just an example of how the
language is cross over and you you can
apply one to the other but they're
generally not mutually comprehensible
you have to make the effort to shift it
to change that knowledge into the other
language so that's why there are two
different languages not dialects of the
same language all right so that's that's
what I wanted to share with you just my
experience with how similar they are
give you some similarities differences
and hope you understand a little bit
better than before
all right thank you for listening good
night
[Music]
[Applause]